so your brain is probably already
processed this video and what you're
looking at really isn't the true picture
well if you look really closely in about
three seconds
you're gonna see a logo appear right
here one two three
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is David
Simon welcome back to the channel today
we're talking about Adobe After Effects
and an incredible new feature that lets
you remove pretty much any logo or any
little item in the background that you
know shouldn't be there for all you Game
of Thrones fans out there maybe the guys
editing that should use this little
trick to removing it on one item from a
video used to take forever you just have
to keep in and out go through frame by
frame and analyze it and used to take
hours on end to get rid of something
over ten seconds well now thankfully
Adobe After Effects has introduced a
brand new update that lets you key it
out pretty much automatically all you
have to do is press a couple buttons so
before we get started make sure you've
updated your Adobe After Effects the
newest version so you have this feature
too alright so let's dive straight into
the tutorial for this one here we're
going to use that opening sequence where
I remove this logo here to teach you
guys how to do it this is very simple
and doesn't take that much time so
you're able to use whatever video you
have on hand to do this tutorial with me
simply open up After Effects and select
your video down the bottom the first
thing that you want to do is open up the
pen tool and highlight around the logo
or the object that you're trying to
remove
when you've done that you want to move
down to the video and tap the M key to
select mask and you're going to notice
these two layers pop up below here where
it says add you want to click the drop
down menu and move down to subtract and
then after that you're going to come up
to the tracker on the right-hand side of
the info panel make sure that mask is
selected otherwise you won't get the
analyzed option and press play this is
going to track everything frame by frame
now it's going to take a little bit of
time to sit back relax and let the
program do all the hard work for you
once that tracking process is complete
you can come down to the content-aware
fill underneath tracker if you don't
have it active already you can come up
to window and go down to content aware
fill but if you do have the latest and
greatest version it's going to be there
by default once you're into this little
panel here all you have to do is click
generate fill layer so I think that took
less than two minutes to do which is
fantastic news for anybody trying to get
rid of something that they don't want in
their shots if you enjoyed this video
make sure you smash that subscribe
button
20-19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday